this video is brought to you by
manscaped.com
find out more later on
hey 42 here in the 1891 sherlock holmes
story the red-headed league two men gain
access to a bank vault by tunneling
their way through the floor
unfortunately for them sherlock holmes
is one step ahead and is already inside
the vault awaiting their arrival
now for most of us after finishing a
short story such as the red-headed
league we're likely to finish off our
cocoa turn off our night light and go to
bed but not professional criminal
anthony gavin
where others saw the sherlock holmes
tale as a light-hearted piece of
literary entertainment gavin saw a
step-by-step guide on how to rob a bank
in fact gavin was so impressed by sir
arthur conan doyle's bank robbing
blueprint
that in 1971 he decided he was going to
put it to the test the result was one of
the most audacious bank heists in
british history with millions of pounds
worth of valuables stolen from safety
deposit boxes locked away in an
apparently unbreakable bank vault in
central london
that in itself is pretty interesting
but even more intriguingly the heist may
just have uncovered a royal scandal in
the process
one that's been hushed up for decades
more on that a little later
well christmas has come early this year
because i've just been gifted a new
performance package by manscaped and
it's awesome let's check it out and
trust me your jingle balls will thank
you firstly we've got the lawnmower 4.0
this waterproof cordless trimmer is
built with advanced skin safe technology
which actually helps you to reduce nasty
nicks and cuts on your most sensitive
areas and it also has this cool led
light which is really helpful for
grooming during these cold dark winter
nights
now here's a stocking stuffer for you
it's manscaped crop preserver ball
deodorant and crop reviver ball toner
spray these are absolute game changers
oh and did i mention
it also smells really good now gents
manscaped is no longer for just below
the waist grooming they have you covered
from head to toe
quite literally with their new and
improved shears 2.0 their luxury
six-piece stainless steel nail kit
honestly every guy out there needs to be
putting manscaped on their wish list
this season especially because for a
limited time you'll also get two free
gifts the shed travel bag and the
manscaped anti-chafing boxer briefs
that's literally a gift on top of a gift
so don't wait around go to manscapes.com
42 to get 20 off plus free international
shipping plus two free gifts
your balls and your body will thank you
before gavin could begin tuttling his
way into a bank vault like some giant
money-hungry badger he first needed to
choose a suitable target and it seemed
he had an eye for symbolism because he
ended up selecting a branch of lloyd's
bank that just so happens to be situated
on the corner of london's baker street
home of the illustrious detective that
had inspired gavin in the first place
with his target located gavin began
meticulously planning a crime that would
come to be known as the baker street
robbery
to execute his plan gavin would need to
assemble a crack team of accomplices
each of whom will be given a specific
job first on the list was reginald's
tucker a used car salesman whose job it
would be to gain access to the vault
before the robbery took place
bank policy at the time allowed
customers to enter the vault on their
own meaning all tucker had to do to get
a closer look at the target was rent a
safety deposit box
no doubt the bank's employees assumed
tucker was just another wealthy customer
there to gaze upon whatever secret
valuables he was storing in his box
but in reality as soon as he was left
alone in the vault he began measuring
its exact dimensions
this stage of the plan was crucial since
the gang needed to know exactly where to
dig their tunnel of course waltzing into
the vault with a tape measure
might have raised a few eyebrows
so tucker undertook his measuring duties
using the whiff of his arms an umbrella
and the conveniently positioned floor
tiles which were each exactly 23
centimeters long
next on the list to join gavin's gang
was thomas stevens who incidentally was
another used car salesman now i'm not
saying all used car salesmen are
untrustworthy but on this evidence it's
probably best to get a second opinion on
that odometer reading before you hand
over your cash
steven's job was simple it was down to
him to acquire the tools needed to
overcome the heist's final boss
the meter thick reinforced concrete
floor that led to the vault
other members of the gang include the
benjamin wolf who leased the shop two
doors down from the bank that would
serve as the base from which they would
begin tunneling and bobby mills a
lookout whose job it was to update the
gang of any suspicious activity in the
area finally bafta award-winning
comedian and television personality
ricky skinny gervais was drafted in to
take care of the volks burglar a lot oh
sorry that's mickey skinny javazz i'm
always getting those two mixed up
it's widely accepted that there were far
more people involved in this crime than
just a core crew but their identities
remain a mystery to this day
one person often associated with the
burglary is the infamous brian reader
who years later will be jailed for his
involvement in the hatton garden heist a
crime that bore an uncanny resemblance
to the baker street robbery many are
convinced that reader was a member of
gavin's gang but he always maintains
that he played no part in that job
then again he would say that wouldn't he
ma from home alone aside most career
criminals avoid confessing to their
crimes
now that the gang was assembled they
were faced with the daunting prospect of
digging the tunnel and breaking into the
vault the tunnel needed to be more than
12 metres long in order to pass between
the chicken in restaurants that sat
between the gang's hideout and the bank
so to save time the team kept it as
small as possible shawshank redemption
style the entrance was under 40
centimeters across and the exit closer
to 30. it was back-breaking work
regardless
gavin would later claim to have lost
more than two stone in the month or so
it took to excavate the tunnel
the only time in history anyone has ever
lost weight in the vicinity of the
chicken inn on baker street
by the time the tunnel was finished only
one thing stood in the way of the team
and their loot
unfortunately that one thing happens to
be a meter thick and made of reinforced
concrete
the vault floor
it was time for heavy duty equipment
specialist thomas stevens to prove his
worth
first he tried breaking through the
concrete using an industrial jack
capable of exerting a force of 100 tons
but instead of cracking the concrete
above it simply drove itself into the
floor of the tunnel
next he tried a firmic lance which is
basically a real-life version of a
lightsaber capable of cutting through
steel with pure heat
when even that didn't work stevens began
to lose his patience
none of the fancy tools he'd gone to so
much trouble to require were working it
was time to bring out the big guns
well
explosives
gel ignite to be specific
the crew had wanted to avoid the use of
explosives for obvious reasons
they're a little on the loud side for a
secret bank robbery
but they overcome this issue by timing
the blasts to coincide with heavy
traffic noise from the street above
a couple of controlled explosions later
and they were in
up to this point it seemed like
everything was going pretty swimmingly
they've managed to dig a 12 meter tunnel
resisted the temptation of fried chicken
and gained entry to the bank vault all
without raising any suspicions
or at least that's what they thought you
see the team had been communicating via
walkie talkies throughout the heist it
had seemed like a good idea on paper
they were spread out in various
locations in and around the bank
excavators in the tunnel lookouts on
nearby rooftops that sort of thing
walkie-talkies meant instructions could
be given out to everyone quickly and
efficiently
but there was a problem
someone else had been listening in
that someone was robert rowlands a home
radio enthusiast with a name like a
superheroes alter ego from a stan lee
comic
roland had been attempting to tune into
radio luxembourg as one does and kick
back and relax for the evening
but any notion of a quiet night bushing
up on his luxembourgish was quickly
ended when vigorously twiddling his knob
he suddenly found himself listening in
on a live burglary after convincing
himself that no this wasn't some kind of
hyper-realistic radio drama rowlands did
what any good citizen would do and
informs the local police
of course the boys in blue immediately
sprang into action alerted all
departments and headed out into the
night to apprehend the criminals
oh no wait this was the 70s which meant
they did none of those things in fact
instead of you know stopping one of the
biggest crimes of the century the
officer on duty told roland to bugger
off and stop making prank calls
luckily roland was undeterred so he got
back onto his radio slipped a cassette
into the tape deck and began to record
an argument between the gang members
about whether or not they should take a
break or continue tunneling towards
default
apparently even the world's greatest
criminals have hr issues
now armed with hard evidence
rollins gave the police another call
though this time he went straight to
scotland yard the metropolitan police
headquarters dispatched members of its
flying squad to roland's house to listen
to the tapes and any other live radio
conversations the gang might
accidentally broadcast throughout the
night by the way the flying squad
nicknamed the sweeney is a branch of the
police that's dedicated to investigating
organized crime and not a group of
flying police officers who sweep down on
unsuspecting criminals in the dead of
night like truncheon wielding
superheroes
mazda pity
the police sat with rollins through the
night listening in on the gang's
intermittent radio conversations which
confirmed beyond the shadow of a doubt
that a large-scale bank heist was indeed
underway in london the only problem was
at no point did the crooks happen to
conveniently mention
which particular bank they were in the
process of robbing
with no way of knowing where exactly the
crime was taking place the police were
left with little choice but to go and
investigate every single bank in the
vicinity
all
750 of them
at
749 of those banks
absolutely nothing of interest was
happening
but at one the baker street branch of
lloyds a bunch of hardened criminals
were busy emptying the vault of its
priceless contents
the police arrived on the scene when the
heist was still in full swing
but when they got down to the bank's
vault they found it sealed with a time
lock a device that prevented access
apart from its certain times of the day
so what did these seasoned police
officers do in the face of this mighty
time-based obstacle that could have been
overcome by literally doing nothing for
a little bit
let me tell you
they assumed everything was probably
totally fine in there
i'm just moved on to the next bank
whilst nobody knows for sure it's
thought that the robbers were very
likely still inside the vault when the
police arrived no doubt slurling their
collective underwear whilst firing off
prayers to every deity in the dictionary
unsurprisingly considering how close
they'd come to getting caught the gang
didn't stick around for long after that
but it wasn't until the following day
that the location of the crime was
finally discovered when it was staff at
the bank found that
268 safety deposit boxes had been
relieved of their contents
amounting to somewhere in the region of
three million pounds of loot
to add insult to injury one of the gang
members had scrawled let's see how
sherlock holmes solves this one across
the wall of the vault
as you probably already know being a
cocky invariably elicits some kind
of good old-fashioned instant karma from
the universe and this was no exception
because the police weren't going to need
a fictional detective with near
supernatural powers of deduction to
solve this case you see one of the gang
members benjamin wolf his job it had
been to secure the shop two doors down
from the bank
appeared to have skipped the first day
of crime school and had failed to use a
fake name when signing his lease papers
and so before long the police were
knocking on his door to ask him if he
knew anything about a certain 12-meter
tunnel they'd found in the middle of his
shop floor the arrests soon followed
with four members of the gang convicted
for their involvement in the baker
street robbery
anthony gavin thomas stevens and reg
tucker each received 12-year sentences
whilst benjamin wolf received a slightly
more lenient eight-year sentence on
account of his age he was in his 60s at
the time
the police then turned their attention
to the real crime lord in this story
robert rowlands the amateur radio
enthusiast who'd alerted them to the
burglary in the first place that's right
proving the age-old adage that no good
deed goes unpunished the police
seriously considered prosecuting
roland's for listening in on unlicensed
radio transmissions
fortunately they eventually came to
their senses and decided against it
lloyd's bank on the other hand were far
more grateful and awarded roland's 2 500
pounds for his efforts
although four of the gang members were
put behind bars this was far from a
decisive victory for the police as i've
already mentioned to this day nobody
really knows how many people were
involved in the heist and it's thought
that several of the conspirators managed
to evade capture
if that's true i can only assume those
men or women enjoyed a pretty great
retirement somewhere sunny because only
231 000 pounds of the estimated millions
that were stolen was ever recovered but
what about that royal scandal i
mentioned at the start of the video
well for those of you wondering the
queen wasn't in the tunnel with the
thermic lance
unfortunately
no soon after the burglary rumors began
to surface that one of the safety
deposit boxes contained compromising
photographs of the queen's sister
princess margaret on a caribbean island
with british actor john binden who was
known to have strong ties with the
criminal underworld
a love affair with such an unscrupulous
character would have been a huge scandal
for the royals and no doubt they would
have done everything in their power to
prevent the photographs from being
leaked to the press and ultimately the
public
though let's face it even when they do
manage to dodge one scandal you don't
usually have to wait too long for
another one to come around sorry mom
interestingly enough despite this being
one of the biggest and boldest
burglaries in british history
the press appeared to mysteriously lose
interest in the story soon after the
events unfolded
and it's been suggested that mi5 put a
gagging order in place on behalf of the
royal family to hush the whole thing up
of course it goes without saying that
the gang will have seen some things they
were never meant to see as they rifled
through the safety deposit boxes in the
vault of lloyd's bank
but whether or not one of those things
happens to be princess margaret's boobs
is sadly unknown having said that it
might not stay that way
you see whilst most of the documents
relating to the police investigation
were made public back in 2013
locked away in a vault somewhere are 800
pages that were for reasons unknown
kept back eventually those papers will
be declassified and released to the
general public and when that happens the
contents of those safety deposit boxes
may finally be revealed
unfortunately that isn't scheduled to
happen until january 2071 and we might
all be dead by then if only there was
some way of accessing the vault sooner
where the hell did i put my thermic
lance
thanks for watching